foreign
your mind's working
there we go
is this one working
so we we currently do direct
certification with a lot of dhhs
programs like tanf snap
and so to talk about the privacy issue
it would be uh no different than
those existing programs we'd follow a
similar process and that process is
essentially dhs owns that data um
there is
i don't know all the details about the
data but there is mostly automation
where it's trying to match
all of those students using
computers not using human eyes so and
that keeps basically dhs's owns the data
they're getting our student data not d
now we're getting dhs data but it's
going to dhhs they're doing the matching
through an automated fashion and it's
it's pretty effective sometimes it's not
100 effective in a sense that there's uh
exceptions that pop out and then that
requires some
eyes from doe to look at some of the
data look at the student data look at
the direct certification and see if
there's matching but for the most part
that that is an existing process so if
we were to enter this program
um it would follow those same processes
so the same
privacy controls we have
with our existing programs that interact
with dhs would also
be used for this program so it would be
um
as far as the privacy concern that would
be how that would play out
just about title one
it would change
so our title one allocation is and i
don't know all the details about title
one because that's not my program
but new hampshire gets kind of the uh
we're called the bare minimum state we
get the bare minimum from the feds so i
don't think it would change i don't
think entering this medicaid direct
store program would change the amount of
money we get through title 1.
it would change
we use fnr data to allocate it out so if
we get a lump sum of
40 million we allocate it out based on
fnr data so it would change potentially
how it's allocated out but the 40
million necessarily wouldn't change
yes representative heath thank you mark
so it would mean that the manner in
which
the funds go to school districts would
become
more accurate
if we went into this system
because right now we know that
especially high school children and
middle school children are apt to not
apply for free and reduced lunches
but in fact if their families are are
eligible then it would be noted as such
correct so it would um it would be less
contingent upon people filling out the
application and more contingent upon
what eligibility what means tested
programs are they currently enrolled in
including medicaid which is a very
popular program
so it would increase the fnr numbers we
don't know by what amount but it would
increase the amount of
uh
students in poverty that we are able to
identify using that automated system so
it would ultimately find more students
in in theory you could have 100 of
students fill out the application but we
suspect that's we know that's not
happening
so yes it would likely improve the
accuracy
thank you very much madam chair and
thanks thanks mark for being with us uh
this morning um when you say um
medicaid school is a very popular
program how how does that
um i mean i think what you mean is it's
a a a highly accurate it accurately
reflects a a population
um
how
how much more accurate is medicaid to
schools
as a proxy for low income families than
let's say free and reduced price lunch
um so let me um i'll just be i think i
said meditated to schools and that's a
whole other thing i'm just talking i'm
sorry and i i think i misspoke um so
students
um enrolled in medicaid is what kind of
just one of the term i was using yeah
and by popular i just mean um uh
uh
it's a larger number of students so we
we currently direct sir so we have
around 40 000 fnr students and we using
our direct search system um almost i
don't have the exact number but a large
majority are those direct our direct
cert um and we use direct cert as a
validation so some people fill out an
application and at the same time they
direct cert so we kind of catch them on
on belts and suspenders catch them twice
in the data set
i don't know i'm
i just believe medicaid since we have
and here's the number we got from dhs we
have 70 000
uh children ages 5 to 17
um
enrolled in our medicaid program that
and then i think we we got the data from
director lipman with uh dhhs and i think
he used 196 percent of the poverty
guideline
um def in our program is 185 so just
using the data he had he could get us
within 196. so we got us pretty close so
what that tells me is there's
a lot of children ages 5 to 17 on
medicaid but they're not necessarily
filling out applications they're not
necessarily in tanf snap or some of the
other programs so that's all the only
insights we can glean from that from
that data
representative vlad
thank you um
medicaid to school is a whole different
program and we don't want to go there we
we've gone through that in the last
three four years here um i was i was
concerned though when you talk about
title one
and and how that's impacted by free and
reduced we also have other federal
programs
which also are contingent upon
federal dollars based upon poverty
and carl perkins is one of them
is the carl perkins
to be eligible for those dollars
are there programs or states which are
using the medicaid approach to
identifying poverty other other than fnr
i'd be curious to know so that we if we
go this direction we're not going to
lose revenue on another side the coin
and i'm talking now career technical
education
yeah i can't speak to the uh details of
the that that federal grant for cte um
i don't know
i'm not sure unsure how it would
potentially risk federal dollars there
well jeff bearden probably would have
that information
if we could just make sure we get that
clarified for us before we step off the
deep edge here
i can pose that question to jeff thank
you
are you sure
are you sure poverty feels well yes on
that side not in the program we have not
in our state appropriations but on the
federal dollar we get from carl perkins
it is based upon part of that formula is
contingent upon poverty
okay
yes represent murray thank you madam
chair um two questions
thank you for explaining about the
automation for the privacy issue i think
you know you did a nice job moving the
human element out of it but someone is
going to ask what happens if someone
gets into that program you know if a
human person has to go into it for some
reason
can you say what it is that actually see
because this is you know pertaining to
the privacy and whether or not mary jo
is in the program or not
um and the second thing can someone just
for my own education
why
are we and what is a bare minimum state
uh so as far as the privacy what they
would see they would not see so the
department of education uses acid which
is a unique identifier for students uh
other programs i believe dhhs is using
something like a social security so um
i i don't think they would
uh i whenever whenever someone at doe
sees the social security numbers they
immediately like they should never be
seeing that so um i i don't think they
would be seeing that detail i think it
would stay within this acid because the
only information they need to identify
the student is
first name last name and date of birth
because those would be the and basically
what they would be looking at is those
those data sets or those three data
points and they were going okay is the
automation
choosing the exception because um uh is
it matthew or matt something like that
so that's really what they're
identifying so first name last name date
of birth and they go okay if it's date
of birth and there's a matthew and a mat
and they have the same last name uh we
think we can certify this because it's
in their their town of residence maybe
as well um i don't know all the data
sets but something along those lines and
it would be the minimum amount of data
data necessary to to do the matching
with validity um as far as bare minimum
state
um
i i think it i don't know exactly but i
think what happens is and this is an
interesting thing uh to point to what
representative lad was talking about we
have two different allocations we have
the allocation done
done among the 50 states and then these
we have the allocation dental to the
districts and so new hampshire
typically
with a program like title one
we use fnr data to allocate out to our
districts but the way the u.s government
allocates and this is just title one i'm
not talking about the cte federal grants
but the way title one works is the u.s
government uses u.s census data and so
historically
this new hampshire has not liked u.s
census data on the way when they get to
the granularity uh the policy position
of the state has been that has not been
a good data set to use u.s census data
instead using fnr data so
i think u.s census i think u.s
government looks at u.s census data and
determines
new hampshire does not have poverty
levels sufficient to provide excess
funding
representative heath
thank you ma'am cheer mark thank you um
isn't it true when i was at the
department
anyone who saw or had access to any
names
for
sacid or because they had to do some
kind of matching
had to sign um a form
saying that they promised never to
disclose so it was like a disclaimer
that they they had to sign at the point
in time i'm presuming that the
department continues that practice
yeah so uh there's the education privacy
law you know we're all familiar with
hippo with our health information with
education it's ferpa
um
we all are
have to uh uphold ferpa i i don't know
i i don't know i don't see a lot of i
don't see that data i don't see um names
and if
if a name ever comes across me i'm
always
our policy is shut it down like do not
you know do not tell me a name if a
district's talking to me and they use
student names i ask them to stop doing
that
sometimes they do that because that's
how they know the students but that's
not how i should know the student i
should know them by sasab um so that's
that's our policy i don't know if the
data people are likely uh they're
educated i know they're educated on
ferpa i don't know what they're signing
but we certainly are aware of our
responsibility to follow federal privacy
education laws
uh i do have one question and this deals
with um
the ability of families to opt out
that
seemed to be something so
is it
would it be feasible or possible
to
send the
student identification number
to the various school districts
and have them figure out if the parent
wants to opt in or opt out
i that um
i know that that question came up in the
senate education and i think i was
talking with with um
d.o.e was talking internally what that
would look like not exactly sure but i
think the way it would look like is we
would send the direct certification
information to
the district the district would become
aware that these students are eligible
for free meals
and so i think the parent would have to
then go to their district and say i
unders like basically take me off the
list um so i think that's how it would
mechanically work um so there would be
an opt-out
uh but it would be an opt-out at the
local level not at the state level
okay
i just um
i just think if we're going to move
forward with this legislation
that we need to have some sort of
opt-out provision at the local level not
at i agree not
so not at the state level karen sure um
so
popped out we have opt out with free and
reduce right now the parent just doesn't
fill the forms out and doesn't submit
them in that's our problem our problem
is that the high school students there's
that tremendous waterfall effect of qual
those people eligible seeing that they
don't fill the forms out
so what are we going to gain by going
with medicaid if they're going to not
opt in to this particular program it
seems to me that
we're going to have them opting out
either way
no
they would automatically be in
unless the parent opts out
of medicaid
ops out of free and reduced lunch
i don't think you have to connect it to
three months yeah
i'm not sure based on what what mark's
talking about that you have to connect
it to free and reduced lunch
this is
really from a from a doe a new hampshire
doe
funding
formula basis through the direct
certification oh i see what you're
saying okay so i think what a little bit
of miscommunication here but i will
representative umberg is talking about
is um because we have two different uses
of the data so
we would direct and this is interesting
i guess now this is brings up a good
question
um
for the family so we direct certif say
you have one student they're in high
school
and they're eligible they're in the
medicaid program
receiving medicaid services et cetera
ella medicaid insurance
now they're attending the high school
the parent decides that they don't want
that high schooler to
um
enter the fnr program so then we would
have the local opt-out where that family
and that student would go to the
uh their school and opt out of the fnr
program but now that's an interesting
point is
do we still record them in the
f as fnr and the adequacy and i
i think mechanically we would we would
yeah i i would certainly agree with yeah
but
they're
at the local level what they're opting
out of
is
i think all of the schools now have like
credit cards
right that
that
you know that's that's what you used to
pay right they're opting out of the
lunch program and that
you know i just
i just know that we need an opt-out yeah
yeah but
but mark what why would
why would the department
have to what
let me ask a different way could the
department shift away from using uh free
and reduced price lunch
and and use the the um
the
basically the
medicaid
numbers that have matched with with
acids we would use the medic in my
opinion
we would use the medicaid number
the fact that a child at the local level
opts out
really would not have
an effect on
the
what we'll call the free and reduced
lunch
um
whatever right so
right it would be a medicaid adm per
school right but we don't want to call
it that we want to call it free and
reduced lunch
okay
because that's
that's we don't i don't think i'll be
right with you tom i don't think
with this legislation
you know if it moves forward
that
we need to change the names
all we're doing is
looking at a behind-the-scene
different method
of determining
the
free and reduced lunch numbers
yeah act accuracy
uh representative bucco
thank you manchester
um so as i
understand
the
um
automatically
including the numbers
for from medicaid
we we we need we wanted to do that so
that we would have more accurate
numbers for our state program for for
the act of previous adequacy grants
and so
that's what we would still be using but
even if they wanted to opt out of the
lunch program that
shouldn't affect that
is that right and that's what we want to
do that's that's correct
that's correct
i just actually got that
congratulations tom you got it but i'm
not there yet
[Laughter]
medicaid
who has the medicaid information is it
dhhs or doe does doe have any of that
information right now
uh nhet has zero information on that oh
doe has zero information on it that's
what i thought now for us to get does or
allow or enable doe to capture this
information
are they going to have to is dhh gonna
as gonna have to have
not the safety but department of health
and human services going to need
statutory authority to release that
information or do they just need
parental information authority
how is this going to transfer over so we
get it captured into our system so the
way the the steps would work is uh and
dh justin when uh so 1627 as amended by
the house included a provision that
mandated no changes in
really state law all it did was say
nh and dhs should work together to get
this accomplished and enter this program
and so from there if say if that bill
did pass the next steps in the process
would be uh um working with
usda and uscms the center for medicaid
services and making sure
um
getting the proper approval from the
federal government so cms would
basically authorize dhhs
to share that data with another state
agency because currently cms highly
regulates who has access to um
i don't know highly regulated but
regulates who has access to the medicaid
data and so uh dhs would not provide us
that data unless cms approved of it
through the entering of the pilot
program process i'm following that
conversation now who where's the parent
come involved in this in terms of the
parent authorizing do they authorize
dollars are coming from the feds down to
our departments to allow them to share
this data
where is the parent involved in this are
they
left out of it so then how do they opt
out
i i don't know the answer of when when a
a parent signs up for medicaid for their
family um i don't know what uh
authorizations or approvals they sign
off on i can't answer that question but
that would be there that would be the
extent of their involvement as is
the parents wouldn't be involved in the
medicaid eligibility process but i don't
think they would have
my understanding of the process i don't
know if they'd have any involvement
outside of that
thank you
well i i think that by sending
the student id number
back to the school
and
saying that
parents have the option to opt out of
the lunch program
would
be the final parental
decision
maybe mary can help me with this one too
uh medicaid to the schools where we the
only way we can get involved with that
program is if we have like a nurse
id
and
that's exactly right so the the
permission for that uh to occur comes
from whom
the parent or from how do how do we know
that that person's a medicaid eligible
student
turn on
turn on your microphone please and so
that
based on
this is years ago when i was assistant
superintendent um the school
um had identified who was eligible
for that service
like anybody on katie beckett
automatically would be eligible for that
um
and
so that the
then the school district follows through
that all services that that child gets
depending upon what they are there's a
sign off on each
of those so we've got the student now
eligible to receive that service
how do we get
the
authorization to release that
information to hhs so we can get the
support and medicaid
i'm trying to get the connection here
i think it's all an electronic
connection
that happens
um
is the parent involved with signing off
saying yes you can go
to
first of all when it's
when you're talking medicaid to school
nothing happens without the parents
signing off on the ibp and part of that
is all of those approvals
and during the conversation during an
iep for those individuals that are
eligible for that service the parent
would be part of that that's part of it
and that's signed off i understand so
there is a sign off there would there be
a sign off in this other program we're
talking which is a distinct separate
program well this is all together
different though i mean this again would
be an electronical
coming together
um it would define accuracy
for the numbers of reduced lunch
students now if i were superintendent
and we have this opt out clause what i
would do is i would work with my food
service program and figure out those
students that are eligible based on the
data that i've received from the state
and the letter would go home to the
parents saying
it has been determined that your child
is eligible for free reduced lunch
period if you don't want to if you you
you aren't if you don't want this
service then you have the um you can
come in and opt out of it or some kind
of language like that so hhs will
release that information to the
superintendent
no no it would have to be at this local
level
just a second the oe
would send the student identification
number
to the superintendent
or whoever
okay
the superintendent would then take an
action
like
representative heath just described okay
at the local level
at the state level
whether they opt out of the lunch
program or not
in my opinion would not affect the
amount of money that we provide to the
schools
right
you know
that's what i would think yeah
okay
so the names public students names are
never
available to anybody um the testing
company even has to do go through all
kinds of things to be able to work on
the test results so it's it's something
that's held i remember if you can
remember neil kirk and what we went
through um to get these programs in
place uh it was just really everything
had to be completely
private and names are held in complete
security
thanks very much madam chair um so when
when when tom very articulately
said he he gets it i thought i got it
too and then when rick was going through
some
sort of digging down i think i ungut it
um
and and so i i want to try to sort of
piece this back together uh
let me ask you a question yeah why is it
the women get it and then
[Laughter]
because you've all been superintendent
oh no no no
that's a good comeback yeah yeah but um
so the the way this is sort of
sounding particularly after what what
rick was when and and mary were we're
talking about it sounds like in a
student record there's a sacid the
student id there's an indicator for
whether or not they're signed up for
free and reduced price lunch and there's
another indicator as as yet no i
understand but at least as far as this
conversation goes and another indicator
of whether their their medicaid um um
either eligible or no
not at the local level
okay so well so the the conversation
that i thought rick um was was going
down was that in order to
check that medicaid box that involves
the parent and dhhs when a student is
looking to receive medicaid services in
the school because the school obviously
would have to know if the student was
was was
medicaid receiving medicaid services
right in order to build cnn put that
thought
away
okay no no no i under i understand so so
the this is about how you go about
checking off that medicaid box in the
student record whether that's whether
that can be done automatically
through the pilot program
it would only
check off at the state level
okay the the school
would not get
anything other than
your these children are available for
free and reduced lunch okay how they got
to it how we got to it
is immaterial
and would not be boxes checked off
in any record
okay so the only thing that the that the
um that the local
would have
is in a student rack i mean among other
things this acid and free ingredient
express lunch correct and and if they
were going down this completely other
unrelated thing to receive medicaid uh
services in school that's a totally
separate conversation between dhhs the
family and the district that's correct
okay thank you okay
so um
mark
is legislation required
for doe to go forward to usda to see if
we can
qualify for this program
so technically no
but the department has asked that this
is a a policy decision that the
legislature needs to determine so we
will not
uh seek to enter the program unless
legislation requires us to do so
so
so what that means is
it won't be effective in the next budget
is what you're telling me
unless i convince
doe
to forget the need for legislation is
that correct
that's one way to look at it yes well
it's the only way to look at it
or or pass legislation or
but but also um and so what am i what am
i going to pass legislation
even if i pass it on january 5th okay by
the time you get
the stuff moving to usda
and by the time you get the information
back
by the time you do all of this
we're talking january of 24.
sorry yeah so you know so
the
let me clarify the timeline the timeline
so if if if
this legislature um passed
1627 as amended by the house that
included the requiring the department to
enter this program that that legislation
is dead yes if it under the hypothetical
they did so if you were to pass it um
say you passed it in june this month um
we would apply we would
uh the department would work to build
the application this summer
uh we would uh submit that application
by september 2022
and then we would
um if we got approved it would impact
school year
23 24 that's when it would go in effect
and it would impact adequacy um so
that's we're already talking outside of
the current budget the point is
that we're not going to get there
because the legislation didn't pass
correct so
with what you said
we would have to submit a bill
in november
which wouldn't come to the house until
january or february or march
and then
the budget is already set up
by that time
for 24 25
so
we would not
be able
to
include that
in the
24-25 budget that's correct okay so
okay
or sorry you could include uh the
dollars wouldn't impact the 2425 budget
but you could
yes if that's if that's what you're
referring to
yes
thanks
but but if it were included in the um
in the budget if the pilot provision was
also included in the budget um could it
it wouldn't it wouldn't be able to come
into effect in time to to to change fy
24 school budgets but it might be would
it be possible that it could have could
come in for fy25 school budget
the biggest problem there is
we don't know
what
that would
be
that's our problem
until we you know
on the budget side
it's difficult to budget for unknowns
and we try not to do that
and so it it is um
you know perhaps you could do something
supplemental in
you know in late 24
for
you know for 25
but the money goes out
they figure out how much each school
gets like in
march
is that right
um
so we do our estimates in november and
then okay yeah we do our final payment
in april yeah so he it's a it's a timing
issue
for
but we could at least
yeah we can do the authority that that's
not a that's not a problem
but it's the implementation
that
i think
would be a good thing
and um
but we can't you know it won't be
implemented until 26.
fully yeah
may speak
the benefits of doing this
far outweigh
continuing the process we're currently
doing because of the inadequacies that
we know were in place
i totally agree
i just um
i just need to um
see if we can uh move forward without
legislation
i i think uh at this point in time uh we
we should try to move forward this
progress there's some real benefits to
it however
to do it without legislation
and to do it without statutory authority
that the department is requesting
um i i think that we're
we better be very very careful on that
i i would suggest that we try to get
some expedited legislation
i you know you can have emergency
legislation as well you know i've done
that before when it came to the power
line coming down from quebec
um
back then with what's his name from uh
coast county larry
rappaport wasn't it yep yeah mountain
chair yes um
so i i i i like what you were you're
talking about very much about about
about maybe uh another uh
uh
reaching out to the commissioner to um
to uh to really you know explain how
important to move how this you know
to move forward with this now
would would put us in a better footing
for uh for being able to use this as a
budgeting tool in the next bionium's
budget and i think
chairman ladd did something similar to
that
with what was it rick
there was a letter that the that you
sent from the from our committee to the
commissioner
with respect to
a particular issue
and maybe
this would be a similar type of
i did that administratively because we
had a vote a majority vote a unanimous
vote of the committee to do that so i've
done that on numerous occasions and i
know that mary guy had done the same
thing previously
so yeah that is an opportunity to take
that more administrative
send it directly from yourself karen
to
here's what we want to do to the
department
and that and i think that's another way
of doing it but i would seek the the
unanimous support from fiscal not fiscal
but from the finance committee and you
get unanimous then i think that's good
yeah well we need unanimous support out
of here
so we're here at this group yeah
okay yeah because
as we know
division two doesn't make any decisions
by themselves
all of our
decisions have to go back to
um whatever the full committee
okay
so
i know that
with
interim study i think we have
what three options
itl
move forward with legislation
or what's the third one
i think it's either recommended okay
either recommend or not recommend
so
um
could uh our assistant clerk
uh
can somebody make a motion to recommend
for
further legislation
thank you mary
i move that would recommend um
house bill 623 for future legislation
do i have a second
thank you
you're excited
well
do you want us you know
i would probably not we're not
technically part of yes you are
you're part of this i'll be glad to make
okay
on anything here all right let's let's
do that then
and that way it shows both finance and
education
okay
just try to find out about carl perkins
for me will you please
yeah we'll uh we'll let mark
yeah unless mickey
mickey
oh
do you have any idea on carl perkins
sure do you have any idea on uh
represent lad's question on carl perkins
probably not if mark doesn't but i
didn't hear the question representative
ladd
jeff beard has to answer that
we had a briefing about how we
arrive at the amount of money we have
for carl perkins to supplement our are
what we appropriate locally as a state
for cte and he indicated to us at that
meeting that that part of that formula
comes in the play of poverty
and and so that's based upon fnr
so i would assume then if we can do what
we're trying to do here that that would
also
i would think
how many other states are doing medicaid
are five or six of them are so oh it's
yeah and so they must
be doing it somehow
according to
okay
uh
according to the email
from jen
california florida
massachusetts nebraska
utah virginia
west virginia connecticut
indiana
iowa michigan nevada texas washington
and
wisconsin is that right jen
i'm just reading your email
oh oh
december 13th
so wouldn't a quick call to
one of the commissioners in those states
just you know should they already asking
they've already talked to the people in
massachusetts
they had a long conversation with and it
that it's not impacted our title one or
any other federal programs that the word
information is just as valid for these
i think what i think what mark said
and i
believe this to be correct
is that because
our
poverty rate
is so low
we only get the minimum in title one
is that what you said
or am i misinterpreting it's using i
just know that the title one allocation
doesn't use uh fnr data it uses u.s
census data and i believe it's because
our u.s census data shows us not as a
poor state um
right yeah yeah so um
do you have jeff's phone number
not on me oh does representative
look
okay um but let's clear this up
befo before we
take our vote
you see if i've got it
ah
okay
you want to dial
603.
okay
3729 oh i probably shouldn't have done
that over them
folks please do not call jeff beard
today he's
hard at work
and that's what we need him to do sorry
okay
could the uh
assistant clerk call the role of
everybody that's supposed to be here
thank you mayor chair
representative petroville yes
on
recommending for further legislation for
house bill 623
uh
representative bucco
representative heath yes
representative murray yes
representative ladd yes
representative
right there luna yes
um i'm on the other page
think
we gotta oh
representative burger
yes
is that what is
yeah i think that's it
seven of us yeah madam chair the vote is
seven to zero to improve uh further
recommendation i mean uh you know
recommend for future legislation okay
for 623 all right thank you
representative heath
madame chair could i also ask that as an
interim study committee that a letter be
pinned to the commissioner of education
asking that he reconsider his initial
decision
to require legislation for this purpose
okay
i will do that after we have
our full committee vote
oh
okay
and
madam chair
yes following on representative heath's
um suggestion would it uh would it would
it be
appropriate for that to come from both
the chair of finance as well as the
chair of education
okay yeah great thank you
okay
any luck
yes um so whenever we think about
allocations we have to think about it
two different ways we think of the us
government allocation to all 50 states
and territories and then the state's
allocations to the districts and the way
the top-level allocations which is our
total amount of dollars we'll receive
for perkins for
the us government to allocate it out to
the states it's based on population so
not fnr just purely population um
didn't give me too much more details
than that but it does not involve
poverty but the way we allocate it out
from the state to the cte centers that
uses f r data so it wouldn't impact the
total dollars amount we received from
the us government
so no net change there in federal
dollars the state receives but it would
change just the same with title one just
the same with adequacy it would change
the distribution between the districts
pretending on how the direct certs
work out
okay thank you that explains how fnr is
involved in that program but on our
level yes thank you
okay is there anything else on 623
uh reps and heath there is um one aspect
of 623 that that i think um we don't
want to lose um
the um
it refers to school years 22 and 23 but
it's the concept of that i would like to
see that we think about uh that each
municipality shall
um
not be less than they'll receive not
less than the amount of such grant in
the prior year
um
that i don't want to be doing talking
about stabilization but i think in terms
of
just being a former person who had to do
a scuba budget um
not knowing how much money you're going
to get from year to year is disastrous
so if you know you're getting an
allocation of 11 million dollars in
adequacy
in 22
um but then all of a sudden in 23 your
numbers drop drastically and all of a
sudden you're going to get 7 million
dollars
i think there
might be something that we could look at
for the biennium
am i making any sense
uh yeah yeah um
mark i don't know why you ran away
do you have any clue
as to
what happens from year to year
with the various school districts how
much difference
is there
in the adequacy formula
no and what actually goes to the schools
i mean we've we've put in stabilization
which
still annoys me
but i know it makes you happy
yeah but the point is if you don't have
stabilization
then
it drops significantly
so this year when we saw what happened
with cobit we saw drastic drops in
school enrollments that could
significantly impact what the october
one count
in one year was so different from the
october account in the next and not that
this this was an anomaly absolutely and
maybe it should be just something that's
done in the event that we have another
covent
or another pandemic or something that
impacts enrollment but it just for a
school district to see such
changes a fluctuation in just a matter
of one year was totally unusual
what
year do we use now for figuring out
i think that we passed legislation
that went back to
pre-covered
so that
only for free and reduced price lunch
not not for
not for the a.d
well
we did one speak on the statistics
we did um one
mark
make eight just tell me if i'm wrong but
school districts received a separate pot
of money
based on the 2019 numbers
this past september
but then we did another bill that just
made it for the free reduced lunch
numbers am i correct or am i wrong i
could be wrong well we didn't do any
excuse me we didn't do anything free and
reduced because everybody's getting free
and reduced lunch
and that it only ended
only ends the end of this month
i'm not mistaken
so go ahead
uh you're getting very into the weeds
that relates to your role in the city of
manchester as far as the pot of money
and how that's used so without getting
too far into the weeds just to run
through the formula
fiscal year 21 we had about 167 000
students
that's looking at school year um ending
29 uh 2020 so pre-pandemic school year
so 167 000 students
that's fiscal year 21 fiscal year 22
there was an enrollment hold harmless
that looked at all metrics sped uh
regular base adm fnr etc and went back
to that 2020 school year that was not
impacted by the pandemic then in fiscal
year 23 and we're all i think we're all
on the same page here we all understand
this but fiscal year 23 we're just doing
the f and r hold harmless um uh that
essentially looks back at the ratio of
what you have for fnr for 2019 2020 but
then fiscal year 24 we're going to use
there will be no modifications to the
adm data in fiscal year 24.
yeah
mine is pairing to the car outside in
the garage down below
mary i think that um i'm sorry
representative heath i think that's
something that we can um
discuss
in
division two
at budget time i don't i don't
necessarily think that um
i just don't i don't know what
what the differentiation is and we do
provide preliminary
money
to the schools in
september
for budgeting purposes
so that they know is that correct it's
november 15th okay so november 15 excuse
me so they do know
what's going to be
the allocation
uh
from this yeah for the following year
because schools budget on a yearly basis
um
so
represent petrie
yeah thank you madam chair uh what was
the population uh in uh fall of 21 if
you have it you must have it
the the school number drop went from
just ballpark here we went from about
a 167 000 for that 2019-2020
and then we dropped down to about 160
000. so 7k drop
for the year you're talking
okay 20
20 and this was 20 21
yeah the fall of 2020 which is the 21
school year okay
sure yes um
so i i was taking a look at these
numbers this morning from the doe
website and put them on a spreadsheet as
mel miller knows i love spreadsheets um
and um and it is it is quite startling
because going i think i ran it back to
when in our public schools we had 100
approximately 185 000 students
and then that sort of tripped down by
about 2 000 students a year
through about 2017 then about 1 000
students a year or 1500 students a year
through 2019 2020
and then
dropped as as mark just said by about
by
8 500 students from 2020 to 2021. so if
we took that sort of i don't know if we
want to call it organic decline of about
1500 students
a year there's about 7 000 students that
that did not enroll
in the in the in the school year
beginning while we were in the pandemic
beginning the fall of of 2020
and
and i think this is something you know
when you take a look at that drop
167.6 thousand hundred sixty seven
thousand six hundred fifty eight to a
hundred fifty nine thousand eighty eight
students so there's the seventy there's
the 8 500 students there and then you
take a look at the number of kids in
charter schools
4 200 to 4 500
non-public schools um
50 little almost 16 000
little below to a little above
um and
and the home school number sitting
around six thousand i don't know the the
students were not um
identified by the department as being in
any other educational settings
and
well we hope they they are but but we
don't know where they are and and i
think that that it would be of interest
for the state to really understand that
and obviously
going into
operating during a pandemic and coming
out of a pandemic there's going to be a
lot of a lot of bumps on the on the road
and and i think that's what what
represent heath was was referring to but
i still think we have a um
um we we
it would be good to get an understanding
where these 7 000 students um
um where they're receiving their their
um
you know educational services and that's
that's incl that's 7 000. that's net of
what we were seeing
historically is that or you know sort of
organic
drop in enrollment so i you know i think
there is still a concern there and i
think that could be wrapped up into
a um you know
maybe another bill that um that that
looks at um the adm effects following
the pandemic
i'd be happy to decide
to
send this to our group okay that would
be fine i know that um
you know we have
we have done
several things over the years you know
um
some of which i agreed with some of
which i didn't and that's okay they got
you know they got passed
so um
you know there's certainly no harm
in looking at
what's going on with adm
but the problem i think we all know
is the number of children
that
are entering any kind of education
thing is
dropping precipitously
and uh i think that's um
you know probably true
all across the u.s not not just in new
hampshire but i think we are seeing
a larger drop i have not seen the
demographic
study
of
new hampshire's population but
when our i think our average population
age is like 42 or
something or other like that
they
unfortunately the people of childbearing
age the women of childbearing age
are
not here
part of that's housing you know
part of that's
any number of things is certainly not
jobs but
it is you know housing costs
availability of
affordable housing
any any number of any number of things
so
i will say that i was
at
the town office yesterday and this lady
said
i called
on a rental
at
first thing in the morning and she was
the first person that called
and she said i want the place.
the guy says well don't you want to come
and look at it the owner
she said no i don't want to come and
look at it
i know the house i've seen it from the
outside
i'm okay
he says well i better
wait and see if i get any other
phone calls
so
when he called back at
in the evening
he said that he had gone over
requests
for that
house
and that's just in
conway with a population of 9
600 or whatever it is
but i think unfortunately
that's the kind of thing that's going on
and
some of it is a uh
a result of um
in our area of people moving up there
to get away from the cities and
you know enjoy the good life like i have
and tom has for years
and um
you know the housing shortage that we
have
the good news is that
in conway
we've got
about
close to
probably
four to
at least 250
in the next couple of years and probably
another 250 in
within three years
in new housing so
that's a good thing but um
they'll be
they'll all be taken
right away so
anyhow okay i appreciate it and
i will
since we can't meet in july and august
i will schedule something for early
september
for the um
full finance committee
okay
and uh we have two bills this afternoon
uh unfortunately i have a meeting
with the
speaker at one o'clock
so joe will be
taking care of it hopefully you've read
read them all um
anyhow
that's all i know so thank you uh mark
for being here this morning thank you
jen for
all the work that you've done on this
um
we'll see you later have a nice day
i guess i should end the meeting thank
you
for another channel
and 1665.
there's a there's a copyright yeah
this is this is the uh
newport uh yeah landfill
with that
i'll accept that motion
i would um let's so we have what what
are the choices to recommend or not
recommend
no well the igl
i'll ship and we can itl
recommend not recommend i i recommend
not to recommend
i
i motion that we not recommend 1300 okay
because i think everything has been
settled
at our last meeting remember when des
was here it seemed that it was settled
second
is that right mickey
yeah we heard from the department last
week that uh
there is an agreement a tentative
agreement with the state and econ on
this matter
and i think the attorneys are just
drawing up papers to
to
i haven't seen any details no
okay
okay so
any more discussion
all right let's go through the list here
this is to
not recommend hb 1300 fna
and i vote
not recommend which is one
and
representative bucco
oh
no
no well well are you are you there's no
there's no more
this is no no no further action
necessary okay yes
so that's
okay
representative heath
and representative murray
all right so we got a vote of four to
zip
for no further action okay so take care
of that now we got to wait till 1 30.
so i guess okay so this is the division
two
welcome
uh
we just have uh one more bill left here
and uh
would you like to speak on your
on the bill at all
go ahead
thank you and good afternoon my name is
representative judy aaron
and i represent sullivan county district
seven
which are the towns of akworth goshen
langdon lobster and washington
and um
i'm glad to see that you're getting
together for this interim study on this
bill that i proposed 1665
which sought to establish a municipal
road and bridge disaster relief fund
that would be used for infrastructure
repairs in order to facilitate the safe
passage and access on municipal roads
and bridges
and so the the impetus uh the reason why
i brought this bill to the house was
because
there was no
statutory
uh
vehicle or mechanism
which
came to the aid of
towns
that suffered uh catastrophic damage to
their infrastructure
and
when the july 29 floods hit acworth last
year
we were struggling to
find immediate funds
to help
put us back together
uh quickly
and
so my idea was that we should have some
sort of
uh disaster relief fund
that towns can draw upon in the event of
a disaster
and that's what this particular bill uh
sought to
to remedy
i know that we've passed legislation
that
allows for loans to be had from for
municipalities from the state
and that
there are stipulations that come with
that
but i was
i'm thinking that you know it still
might be a good idea to have some sort
of kind of
almost a pool risk insurance policy that
could be set up by the state
for municipalities to draw upon which
they would contribute to uh annually
based on
i mean in in this bill i base it on a
percentage of
their operating
uh
budget
um
i've spoken to select board members
since then and they seem to think that
perhaps you know a flat fee of
500 or a thousand dollars a year might
be more
amenable maybe more towns would join in
on this kind of a fund if it were
not based on a
kind of a side sliding scale
but in any way you know
i also know that we've had along the way
money coming to the municipalities from
the state for road and bridge repair
and i see that also
as
a problem in the way in which the
allocations for that money happens
because it's purely based on population
and if you look at some of the smaller
towns
usually the rural towns are pretty big
in
area size so for instance
akworth only has 850 people but we have
55 miles worth of roads that we we
maintain
and it's a struggle because
75 percent of our operating budget is
roads
money to go to the roads
and we can't simply keep up
on
maintaining them properly and thoroughly
so that in the event of a catastrophic
event there tends to be more damage done
to them because they're not in tip-top
shape
so that's kind of you know the
background if i can refresh memories of
of why i brought this bill to the house
and the senate and
um i don't know what your intention is
in terms of proceeding with it uh given
monies that have been given to towns
and also um you know some of the
uh slight changes that we made to
current legislation that would
uh give loans to towns in the event of
uh an emergency situation
all right will you take questions sure
any questions
thank you for taking my question um we
have senate bills 602 and 609 i believe
that we're both passed in and it was 402
and 409.
402 and four or nine four nine yep
um
and also we have the emergency
301 chapter 301 was it 4-1
the legislation that you showed up the
civil emergency statute yes
rsa 913
and then we have additional funding
going
roads and bridges that again we passed
my feeling is that
we need to give these bills a shot and
see if this does the trick i think we've
heard great stuff from you
from emergency
homeland security
and
i just think we've we've taken the
necessary steps and we we need to see
how that works first before we enter
into setting up another fund plus the
fact we have more money in our rainy day
fund than we've had in a long time so i
feel like we're better poised
um so i don't know for me my
recommendation is not to go forward with
this legislation that's how i feel
thank you
everybody else
mike might go on please
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
yeah yeah thank you
um the bills that marriage that
representative heath just mentioned
senator bill 409
um
did
was what is the status of that did we
pass that
yes so that that was that was supposed
to
um
kind of coordinate with 1665 so that
but
i guess one of them was
there was one was a loan and one was a
grant or something like that this this
came this money would have come out of a
sort of a insurance risk pool kind of
thing
right but
the other legislation that we passed is
is a loan from the state
so
senate bill 409
made changes to the loan program that's
already in existence that's been in
existence since 2017.
senate bill 402 created a new mechanism
and mechanism that a municipality could
apply for up to 50 percent of the
reimbur 50 percent of the state or the
seemingly the local match of the
female reimbursable costs correct
yeah
just to follow up mr chairman so that so
that means with that but those bills
that would that did get passed
municipalities won't be stuck out there
waiting forever anymore like what
they're like they were before
there would be something in statute that
would allow for a municipality to seek
grant funds that currently does not
exist that's what senate bill 402
would do
that that was not really grant though
it's loan money 409 is the loan program
that would be paid back 402 would be up
to 50 percent of the cut the state would
share the local costs but that's after
the fema reimbursement happens yes
correct so they'd have to wait for that
money
yeah the department could speak to the
timelines a little bit but yes this
would be on reimbursable costs
yeah
my point is just that there's something
there that
you know your guts we did do something
wasn't there an option and one of those
uh for the loan that the state could
um
forgive the loan basically i think that
was also an option for some of the
smaller communities possibly
i think that was another another
it was in
another
there was a language in there somewhere
but i don't know where that is exactly
i think you could be thinking that it
was no interest but i don't think it was
under the loan program any mechanism
that there would be anything forgiven
right it was an august incident i
believe would wasn't that the august
incident today
correct and they and they they're
thinking about forgiving more of the
loan
or taking on the state's going to take
on more of the
payments
i'm not remembering
that the
yeah no not not totally no no no there's
no there's really no
grant money immediate grant money that's
available to a town who needs it
but one thing i do want to keep in mind
whether this bill goes forward or not
in the future when when there are road
and bridge funds available to these
towns
that we take a look at doing an
allocation not based on population alone
perhaps on
miles of road that the town maintains
well we we did have one bill that uh on
bridges
that covered the
and and actually we decided that in
finance here
that i believe half was based on the
amount of square footage you have of
bridges bridge deck yes and and also
population so it was half and half so
that would help a town like yours a
little bit i mean i when i looked at the
the allocation chart acworth got what
seventy six thousand dollars which isn't
gonna help which isn't going to help
very much i mean let's face it even
though we
these bills that we've been putting out
for road and bridge um help
tax on you know tax relief
they've been great
but
for a small town who has 850 people they
always get crumbs they get nothing of
the millions of dollars that we send out
there
and um
you know while we're grateful for
whatever we can get from the state to
help
when you look at what roads and bridge
takes to repair
it costs the same whether you're a big
town or a small town whether you have
850 people or
850 000 people
so i think that going forward one of the
things that we have to be very sensitive
in in road and bridge funds coming from
the state
is not just basing it on population we
have to do more to get
more funds to these smaller towns that
have to maintain
larger areas of roadways and bridges
so i hope that the finance committee can
take that back and and look at that next
time we're dealing perhaps in budget
cycle if we're looking to give more
money out to
municipalities for roads and bridges to
figure out a different way to allocate
the money out to towns and municipal
municipalities
but
version of murray can you um i guess
elaborate a little bit longer about you
said that you have 55 miles of
road in this community
are those all municipal roads or on some
of those state roads where you would get
i mean that's 55 miles of town municipal
roads that we maintain
i mean we do have how much we do have
route 123a that goes through our town
and that's state
um maintained
so but um
and and there was some from july 29
flooding there was some damage done on
those roads as well which
the state has come out and kind of
patched up which they're kind of
in need of work now too
but um
you know we're still in our town we're
still really working hard to get through
repairs i know my road forest road
uh was just temporarily repaired and
it's already you know the sides are
falling out and everything and it's
gonna have to be a total redo
i don't know when the planning board and
uh town selectmen have decided when
those roads are gonna be actually fixed
but um it's
it's hard for us because
like i said we're
a town of 850 people that tax base is
very very small compared to others and
compared to the amount of other road
repairs that we have to keep up with
so
yeah yeah and you you know you take a
look at
how many years a decade of of what we've
put into our road infrastructure and
overnight everything was destroyed so
you know you now you got to put pay
catch up play catch up with it and
certainly working with fema
has taken a long long time we're still
waiting for funds to come back to us
i even had
selectmen from leemster call me
because they did after the july 29th
flood they did all their road repairs
and they are waiting now from
reimbursement from fema for the for the
road repairs that they did in the
meantime they have no money left in
their fund balance or in their budget to
pay their bills and they're trying to
figure out
how we're going to do this they've had
to take out um
one of the tax anticipation notes
and um you know it's it's hard when
you've got a small community
with not a huge tax base to to keep up
with that
and this is the kind of
fund or
mechanism
that perhaps would help a town
in need
uh
any other questions for
okay sure thank you
thank you very much for your
consideration
good afternoon i'm jen harper i'm the
director from homeland security and
emergency management and with me is
vanessa yurango my i'm sorry what was a
vanessa vanessa urango you are a-n-g-o
and she is in charge of all of our uh
disasters for the state of new hampshire
thank you
so just one comment uh and vanessa can
probably elaborate much more than i can
on the
putting money like in a risk pool or
something like that
i think we had chatted about this
earlier in the
year
and that if
that happens it's like having insurance
and some of the projects would not be
eligible for fema reimbursement if
there's a pool of money that towns can
go to so just kind of a
remembering that off the top of our
heads
um
you had a question i did um
um in the the actions we've taken some
actions
and the governor has authority to
mobilize the state agencies so i think
there are things we've we've really made
uh i think we've taken action
uh to kind of mitigate what what
happened
and
do you believe that the steps we've
taken
really
um
would kind of not eliminate what
happened in in in your hometown
but would um
kind of mediate a solution in a in a
faster
manner
so that we really don't need 1665
because we have other pieces of
legislation in place right i think with
what
we've all talked about this session
and making the change for communities to
get a look non-interest loan up front
you know
immediately
to help them with some of their exp
immediate expenses for emergency work to
be done and to get that money back
quickly would
be great
i know that vanessa and her team
speaking just for acworth
meet with the town on a weekly basis to
go
where the projects at where are they
with development of the project does
that happen immediately when
when something happens would will now
will that happen immediately so do you
want to just quick
talk about that process i'm sorry to
interrupt you but i see her shaking her
head yeah
context is good yes um
so
when this process starts immediately
after disaster it is a pretty
significant amount of time that has to
that occurs between the disaster
incident and when fema's program
actually gets off the ground
um in many cases it's multiple months
before a disaster declaration takes
place then fema has to mobilize to the
state
where the issue has occurred and the
program gets spun up from there so it's
not an immediate process by any means
but the governor maintains the authority
to initiate
disaster aid to the local community
does he not
in what has that ability
in what sense
in terms of getting state agencies
to assist a community right so if
something so like what happened out in
cheshire and sullivan county back in
july of last year
i am so the state emergency operations
center opened up we were getting reports
from local communities what's going on
out there d.o.t was out there state
police was out there you know we're
trying to see what other resources a
community may need for that emergency
right then right there that night when
the water's coming down the roads and
then the next days afterwards
but like vanessa said the money and the
work that we need to do
after the fact
is
quite lengthy
so there's been no and representative
aaron can
confirm this but there's been no
projects that have been obligated in the
town of akworth have we obligated other
projects
um
for the disaster very few so it is
a the fema process for recovery is a
very long process
so the what the towns can do is go and
ask for that loan hey we need you know
however many
thousands of dollars
yes they could ask for it but it was
with interest
yes representative murray
i think she just answered the question
i'm saying with
the this set of mechanisms that's in
place
the state can release that can release
money earlier than it used to before
which to help get the um the
construction of the repairs underway
before fema comes in so the money can
move more quickly to the community so
thank you
thank you any other questions
thank you very much
so in terms of your question about
mobilization
when the disaster happened
acworth did ask the state for some help
in terms of
we need signs we need
barricades we need
whatever flags or sand or gravel or
whatever to help fix some of the issues
and prevent people from going to places
that are going to be dangerous and i
know this department of transportation
was mobilized to help the western part
of the state and they sent
resources to that side of the state
however that being said a lot of that
mobilization only happened for state
roads
when we and we did ask for barricades
and that kind of thing and
were able to get
some things from uh the operations
director of department of transportation
but not a lot of stuff and we were
actually directed to go to um there's a
a mutual aid for municipalities an
organization for mutual aid that towns
do have to pay a fee to belong to
so we got in contact with them as well
but unfortunately you know they had
resources going to other places too
and were not able to get us trucks or
sand or gravel or whatever we needed
so we were really hard-pressed to try
and find resources
in the midst of this disaster to try and
fix roads to make them passable and safe
so that emergency vehicles can get
through for example
and i think that's also an issue i would
really like to see
the state have
um sort of like a swat team or you know
an emergency response team to go out and
help municipalities
for non-state roads because what they
deal with is state stuff
they don't they their their
purview is not
municipalities or municipal roads
if they had some sort of an emergency
dispatch
crew that can come out and help
the municipal road crews that would
really be
something that would be helpful and
that's
anything i wanted what i wanted to add
thank you
entertaining motion
i'll move um
hb
1665 for um
no further action
anybody want a second
brett murray
any discussion
further
no further action no further
all right are we ready for a vote
okay i vote
yes on no further action for hb 1665.
representative bucco yes
representative heath
yes
representative murray yes
and the vote is four to zip
for no further action thank you very
much
i'm sorry yes i did
yeah i get to write it down i get to do
everything
it's fun
well not i'm not the clerk of this
committee i'm the assistant clerk of
this committee
all right i've been dead i don't think
there's a real designation for that so
we're all set thank you very much
everything is better than it was
you